we're in Inglewood California we're
gonna eat a bunch of vegan soul food let
me tell you something about soul okay so
Daisha here is in another video right
now she's doing a 30 day vegan through a
challenge what do I know about soul food
I think mac and cheese I think Fried
Chicken I think cornbread in wood like
many low income areas of Los Angeles
really struggles to feed people quality
healthy food welcome to stuff I eat the
bet open this restaurant in 2008 to try
and combat that issue she's inspiring
the community to understand food they
love in a broader context I think we can
put it on you to come over the rubric
this is all based around a party in your
mouth alright so the first thing is a
shindig okay if things are oh wow this
is great I probably eat this on my own
time but I'm not like in love that is a
kickback then the next level up is a
house party alright house party and then
if we are just completely
away all that is great
so is this your very first also vegan
soul food platter really so first of all
let me just write exactly what you have
on this plate this is all vegan 100%
vegan kale greens black-eyed peas
we've got mac and cheese vegan vegan
barbecue tofu get a little coleslaw and
potato salad we've got some gluten-free
cornbread and your yam oh my god this
Maggie's is so good yeah I wouldn't say
it tastes like you know like traditional
mac and cheese she's not trying to
imitate regular soulful Mac and she
she's like made it her own and it's
amazing every day I need this every day
the mac and cheese is a house party for
me this is a house party for tofu I've
never had tofu before
what like I've never had tofu in my mind
it's always been like you're scary and
weird yeah we have you'll have this
coleslaw this is a great no the cult the
ghost laughs amazing
Stasia right so you're good I played
almost on Freddie
pick up that page I'm coming I'm coming
I'm coming
what's your definition of like a balance
back what did you expect me to say when
we first moved over here I introduced
the soul food platter it was only going
to be a special couple of the local
residents came in they had the soul food
platter they liked it and then I didn't
have it like the next day and they were
like whoa what happened to that and I'm
like well it was just a special they
walked out that happened several times
several weeks in a row and we just made
the soul food platter a part of the menu
and I think that's how we became the
vegan soul food restaurant why did you
want opening I live down the street
first of all every time I wanted a
decent vegan meal I had to drive across
town there are a lot of health-conscious
people living in this community the rent
was amazing I'm not paying $20,000 a
month for rent miss me Beverly Hills and
they needed me here they needed this
situated right here where it is and why
not why not a good vegan restaurant in
my community so since you've been here
how do you notice that more
the neighbor that it started to come
definitely aren't eating we've just come
for the most of my customers are not
vegan I'm so grateful that that I was
introduced to this life down and made
the transition I really am it I started
at age 40 and I'll be 65 and be simple
I can still jump down and do my push-ups
I'm still running Hills I'm not on
medication my life is wonderful right
now you know I've never for one second
thought about becoming vegan but I'm
actually legitimately considering now
biking with how good the food is and how
good you look
yeah if I can just say one thing if
there are any kids out there eating
those spicy Cheetos
maybe you shouldn't eat those things and
that's all I have to say about spicy
Cheetos I know we're not talking about
spicy Cheetos
you